blake snell on the hill tonight for the
friars
28 year old making his sixth start
because the four seamer the changeup
slide and a curveball really last two
times out against the dodgers very very
well fewer hits than innings pitched
still looking for victory number one
for blake snell as a padre one down here
in the first inning it brings up daryn
ruff
2-2 is in there for strike three freezes
rough first strike out of the night for
blake snow
oh that was nice pitch looking like a
slider
yes there's the rotation
frozen
starting tonight's action with a half
game lead top the nl west uh t's from
short left with a great throw to first
base and ends the first inning it's a
one two three first for blake snell the
padres are coming up
on the hill tonight for the giants will
be the right-handed veteran anthony
discovany
de stefani in his seventh year at the
big league level he's 30 years of age
six feet tall 196 pounders what he's
done this year he's been very good
30 strikeouts he got seven walks in 30
innings with a 1-5-0 era and he's a
perfect 2-0
to left-center field and that is going
to drop in for a base head
kent grisham with a hit to start things
in the bottom of the first inning
so first and second nobody out here in
the bottom of the first inning here's
manny machado
this is a fly ball to left field off the
bat of machado ruff going back at the
wall it'll carry out of here
three run home run for manny machado the
fast start for the friars it's three
nothing san diego
well i i posed the question a little bit
ago when's the last time the friars put
up a crooked number in the first inning
well how about may first
don't throw manny machado a hanging
breaky ball in the strike zone brings up
brandon bell
indeedy go yes he did
adam hamari rings up brandon belt
second strikeout for blake's now one
down one on and one out for wilmer
flores 2-2 pitch coming up
to warmer flores
and a swing and a miss struck him out
back-to-back case for blake snell three
in all two down that's a nice slider by
snell
there's a drive to left field darren
ruff moving over and that is off the
wall
gets it back in quickly it's gonna be a
very long single for tommy pham he hit
it so hard mccarran's off the wall
quickly to rough and he can only get a
single out of that and that nearly got
out of the yard and charging his belt
but he swings away it's ground ball to
short stop could be two touches second
fires to first does dubai
we play two tonight from petco park
padres on top three nothing
mike talkman gonna lead it off here for
the giants in the third
line to center grisham coming in on the
sinking liner and he dives forward to
make the catch
at first look it looked like he was
going to get out there to him without a
problem then he realized that thing was
sinking and has to dive to make the grab
for out number one he snags that titanic
takes away a base hit so one out here in
the third inning anthony de slefani
strikes out diesel funny fourth
strikeout for snell two down
and a chopper left side picked by
machado at third spins and fires and
some fancy footwork on the other side by
eric hosmer nicely done
[Applause]
tap foul no
longoria's got it
and that'll end the inning so two ground
balls and a pop-up and the giants are
coming up in the fourth inning
rough checking in for the second time
tatis off his glove and that's the first
hit of the game for the giants
so a hit and a walk and the first two
giants have reached here in the fourth
inning at the tying run coming to the
plate all of a sudden
and evan longoria
swinging a mess and he strikes him out
hey he went back to the well and why not
the bases are loaded for san francisco
and it's a ground ball to shortstop
tatista's second for one on the first
for two double play
nicely done blake still able to induce
the dp that wraps up the top of the
fourth three-nothing padres
here's osmer who's old for one
got him
now the runner goes
buster's throw
got him
myers decided that
i'm not going to get my uniform dirty
the heck of that
duvine's gonna lead things off
high and deep to left and gone his first
of the year and it's three to one i mean
you can almost see the relief
that he felt when he made contact
because he knew right away it was gone
as you say yeah
was set up
this one trickled down the third
baseline snell's got to get it there in
a hurry through about 100 mile an hour
pitch
to get him nicely done by snell uncorks
that
wow
on the play disc afani went to second
here's rough
rough for the base hit to left
disco fountain is going to score
and it's three to two folks
squares it up
two out jump for disc staff who runs
pretty well for pitcher he's athletic
brandon belt uh struck out swinging
tonight and single to left field a one
for two night
swing and a miss and he strikes out
brandon bell
snell strikes out bell to end the top of
the fifth but the giants get two it's
3-2 padre
got him
buster posey hangs on strikeout number
two and that'll bring up nola
got him
mauricio dubon coming up
lined and caught by tatisse
that's a nice little tumble there at the
end as he reels it in it's short on the
sinking liner fernando tatis junior on
the snare
now thomas stella is going to pinch in
here for disco fanny
stella strikes out good start for austin
adams one down here in the seventh
phillip berger as that is strike three
back-to-back strikeouts for austin adams
two down in the seventh
swing and a miss and he strikes out nice
inning by austin adams
[Applause]
that is strike three
one down in the eighth inning
[Applause]
swing and a miss and he strikes out
longoria back-to-back strikeouts for
pagan
for padres pitching that's five k's in a
row two down
jerks in pro far to lead it off
fly ball deep right
field back at the whoa there's your
insurance solo shot to right jericho
profile
padres take a 4-2 lead in the bottom of
the eighth inning and a pro far hits it
so far and as donnie said there's a
little insurance for you osmer at second
to tease it third two down
chronoworth to right field that's in for
a hit here comes tatis here comes hosmer
padres take a 6-2 lead
two down in the ninth inning
mike talkman hole for three in the ball
game
on the ground right side they can stand
as one flip to first
that's the ball game